doctors are questioning whether big tech
companies like Amazon Facebook and
Google share the blame for an alarming
rise in unvaccinated kids the pretends
that their percentage rather of young
children who have not received any
vaccinations has quadrupled since 2001
now this coincides with hundreds of
cases of measles reported here in this
country public health experts worry that
parents are opting out of vaccines after
finding faulty science online Toni
Jacopo's shows us the steps that tech
companies say they're taking to fight
misinformation guess what donated copal
joins us at the table hey Tony hey how
you doing good morning and good morning
to all of you I want to be completely
clear about something and that's this
every major medical body and federal
office agrees vaccines are safe and
effective . but that's often not the
message you get if you're a parent
poking around online amazon Facebook and
Google now all seem to be trying to fix
that but it raises a question where is
the line between protecting the
community and censoring it in my view
everything the science can be questioned
this dish full of disease produce a
greater good is a documentary
challenging the scientific consensus
that vaccines are safe and while it
includes some mainstream scientists is
there an epidemic of autism I think the
answer that question is probably no it's
one of at least five films that Amazon
apparently pulled from its popular
streaming video service after being
contacted by congressman Adam Schiff
they did take steps to de-emphasize the
misinformation they made them harder to
find and harder to get yes and and you
know maybe that's the right balance
amazon declined to comment or even
confirm the move but it came hours after
ship sent an open letter calling on the
company to stop surfacing and
recommending content that discourages
parents from vaccinating their children
what makes you comfortable having these
tech companies decide what should rise
and what should be suppressed
what big responsibility it is I can't
say that I am all that comfortable with
that idea but I think here where you're
talking about an immediate threat to
public health where you're talking about
a very strong scientific consensus I
think that cuts in favor of the exercise
of social responsibility we're slipping
ever closer to tyranny
these tech giants are the ones who are
really driving the bus leslie Manoogian
a producer behind the greater good says
the film had been viewed more than 10
million times mostly online where she
claims companies have now adjusted their
algorithms to reduce the movie's
visibility we have not heard a word from
Amazon we've never heard a word from
Facebook never heard a word from YouTube
never heard a word from Google or any of
these giant tech companies who are
systematically censoring us the American
Academy of Pediatrics sent letters to
some of the largest tech companies
asking Silicon Valley to confront what
it calls the spread of vaccine
misinformation online it's about best
interest dr. Wendy su Swanson is a
pediatrician and spokesperson for the
AAP she says misinformation is crowding
out real science on vaccines endangering
Public Health this feels like a
watershed moment this feels like a time
where everybody's raising their hands
and saying wait a second it matters
what's information to serve up to me and
I want to understand it more Facebook
has pledged to reduce the ranking of
pages that spread misinformation about
vaccines Google says it's reducing
recommendations of content that can miss
inform users in harmful ways and
Pinterest stop serving results for
searches related to vaccines I don't
think it's the government's role to say
you can't publish this content there is
a First Amendment right to say whatever
you will but then why try to discourage
tech companies from offering this free
speech because we are forced to deal
with the problem it creates and that is
public health crises because other
people suffer as a result where's the
line between your free speech rights and
public health overall well listen if I
want to say that climbing to the top of
a mountain causes cancer that should be
my right it's lunacy to say that I
shouldn't be able to say that of course
the question is should it be on Amazon
it's not just films by the way Amazon
has apparently also removed several
books related to vaccines in a statement
to CBS the company says it is mindful of
a global history fraught with book
censorship and it does not take these
moves lightly Leslie's right she has
she has the right to say what she
believes the question is whether there's
a corporate responsibility by big tech
companies Amazon Facebook and Google to
allow give her a megaphone to publish
what is run factual information well we
can go outside and say what we want but
is the digital Public Square now
controlled by these big tech companies
should we also have a right to that
digital public square that's the
question - and this is a problem we're
seeing around the world you know Russian
trolls and bots are being accused of
spreading this information about
vaccines as well and many European
governments are dealing with this very
issue just like we are right it's a big
milestone for tech companies because
they've had policies on on nudity on
harassment on violence now a policy
emerges on truthfulness yeah but you
make a good point that there is foreign
influence behind the spreading of a lot
of this information misinformation that
were used to unfortunately at this point
Tony thank you this is definitely a
talker